great thanks for the introduction
Michael so as Michael said I'm a new
assistant professor in the mechanical
engineering design group and teaching
classes for the product design program
and also around kind of the intersection
between HCI and you know design and the
physical world so anyway today I'm going
to talk a little bit about some of the
work that I was doing at the MIT Media
Lab during my PhD and postdoc and then
also briefly talk about some directions
of the things that are going on at my
lab here which were tentatively calling
the physical inner interaction group but
we'll see anyway so before I get started
talking about sort of what I've been
working on I think you know looking back
to sort of the rich history of tools and
thinking about where tools come from is
something that I think is really central
to our role as designers of of objects
and of interfaces and so these are hand
axes that are that our ancestors made
you know many many years ago and these
were made not only to fit you know the
their hands but also to fit the task at
hand and you know we've evolved with
tools and and tools have evolved with us
and so over time you know all of these
tools have become increasingly
specialized and designers of these tools
have gotten really good at matching
their physical form to both how they
want to manipulate the world as well as
how you want to hold them and so the
physical form matches the functionality
and can harness the richness and
dexterity of our hand but again tools
not only allow us to manipulate the
world tools can also be used to build
other tools that can help us think about
problems and think about space and think
about interacting with other people but
as tools have become more complex we've
you know designed really great ways to
allow for you know the manipulation of
different parameters while you're
attending to different tasks and so
these physical affordances the designers
have gotten very good at at trading
really allow us to to do many different
things Wow
we're not necessarily focusing on them
and the best interfaces are really those
that sort of blend into the background
or sort of become part of the task
itself however I think the computer has
really changed the way that we interact
and also change the way that we think
about tools pretty much you know most
tools that we use on a daily basis now
are either on a computer or used
computers as part of the process and the
thing that's really changed about this
is that computation is dynamic and so as
such it can do millions of different
things so you know your standard
computer can have you know the millions
of different applications that can run
on it but most computing systems really
have the same static physical
affordances for all these different
applications so you're using the
keyboard in the mouse or multi touch
interaction for both you know composing
an email as you would be for playing a
musical instrument or playing a game or
browsing a large data set or modeling
something on a computer aided design
tool and so I think that this is
fundamentally a problem and so my belief
is that we need computers that can
physically adapt to us to match their
form to this dynamic computation as well
and that's what I've been working on at
the MIT Media Lab and now I hope to be
doing the same thing at Stanford and so
at MIT together with Daniel light finger
and my former advisor Hiroshi issue we
build this system in form that allows
you to take digital information and make
it now physical so you can interact with
it directly and you can use that to
visualize 3d information that you can
touch and feel in different ways so for
example you can understand the slope and
curves of a math equation as opposed to
just seeing it or users can interact
directly through touch and gesture to to
sculpt digital clay and so you can use
your hands in different ways that you
wouldn't be able to with a traditional
multi-touch or mouse and keyboard
interface but in addition physical
interface elements can appear and
disappear on demand and the idea is that
for all these different applications
the physical form can reflect these
these things is there a way for me to
have the video show up here sorry to
interrupt yeah yeah it's switching
between me and thing just it's hard to
because there's videos I need for some
reason keynote doesn't show you the
video preview so it's best if I can see
it so my apologies well I try to figure
out this but anyway regardless of that
not not so important so anyway as as I'm
as I was saying we want the physical
form to really match the way that we
want to interact with it and to match
the application and so informed can
really change the way that we interact
with information because now we're
making information physical and so how
might we you know use this type of
system in a more practical application
so Tony tane who is a master student at
the Media Lab worked with Daniel and I
to create this system called cityscape
which allows you to urban planners to
have a physical model of their city and
now as opposed to having this static
physical model that they build they can
move around it and then it can also
become dynamic so you can manipulate the
buildings physically but you can also
look at different data sets and view
those you know as they change over time
and so the idea is to really take sort
of some of the things that we're already
doing in the design process in urban
planning that is building these physical
models and being able to collaborate
with other people by by spatially
referencing them or manipulating them
physically but now we can add back in
that digital component that allows you
to have this rich computational
abilities underneath so obviously
there's been a lot of work that this is
building on and a lot of work in the
space of sort of tangible interfaces
that sort of started out of a
collaboration with George fitzmorris and
osarian and hiroshi ishy and bill Buxton
at University of Toronto and then
Hiroshi Ishii my former adviser had
worked on a lot and with many other
people as well but thinking about how
you can
represent information physically but a
lot of the limitations of these systems
were that that the computational system
is dynamic but these physical interface
elements are not and so there's been a
lot of work before this as well in sort
of haptic interfaces to give you that
more interactive yes water frame brain
needs out oh sorry Kirby's Masonic sure
so is a little bit phrase and
interesting to think about in the
physical world because you can update
something very quickly but then it might
take time for that physical thing to
actually get there so the refresh rate
on our on our sheep display actually
depends on the direction that it's
moving in so for example if you're
trying to raise something up it takes
longer then move down because of gravity
but but we're able to refresh it or rent
around 30 frames per second so that's
kind of the refresh rate there for other
types of haptic systems where you're
thinking more about you know actually
manipulating it you want to have even
higher bandwidth and higher refresh rate
as our tactile senses are actually much
faster than our visual ones yeah so
tangible interfaces and a lot of these
really stem from learnings about
cognitive science and how we think about
problems and how we can offload those
into the physical world and so one of
those notions is this notion of
epistemic action so being able to
externalize our thoughts into the
physical world and so there's been this
rich history of tangibles and then more
recently you know in addition to the
haptic interfaces that have been going
on for a long time there's been working
sort of actuated tangible interfaces
which can use you know in the case of
Pico which was from the tangible media
grip uses magnets to move around these
physical objects or or for example
Fabian hemert shape-changing mobile
device uses servo motors to give you
feedback on these things however most of
these examples can sort of only change
between a few different states or are
limited to sort of 2d interaction and so
another
direction that's been really exciting
that we've built on a lot is this notion
of shape displays where as opposed to
sort of a traditional haptic interface
where you might have you know something
like the haptic phantom where you have a
tethered device that's giving you force
feedback here the idea is to create a
tactile display that you can touch and
feel with your hands but you can also
see it and so that means that it can
allow for multiple users to interact
with it and other things like that so
project felix is one of the the first
ones of these but there's been a number
of others such as Ivan puppy revs lumen
and then a lot of the work from the
media lab however a lot of these systems
have really focused on only thinking
about how do you display 3d information
and so really the focus of our work has
been to think not only about the content
but also how do you create new types of
user interfaces and user interface
paradigms for these new types of systems
and so one of these things sort of is
the central concept to to a lot of
things that I've been working on is this
notion of dynamic physical affordances
that we want to have physical
affordances that can allow the user to
both understand how they can use this
system but they need to adapt to these
different applications and so some
examples of you know what these could be
on the inform shape display because sort
of this kind of low resolution
prototyping platform that we've built
are you know you can render sort of
buttons or sliders on demand and then
they can become you know they can change
their position and resize and they can
be touch sensitive as well or they can
you know morph between input dimensions
so you can have a button that can then
become sort of this touch selector and
so it gives you this continuity between
them or they can also be context-aware
so you can have them resize based on how
close you are there's this target
expansion that's been done in you know
in mouse and keyboard interfaces but now
we can do these types of things in the
physical world and so these parameters
of these dynamic affordances we can
really manipulate a number of different
things so we can change their
shape their size their position and
orientation their color their visibility
as well as the way that they feel so
their haptic feedback so we can change
the stiffness as you're as you're
touching it and I think what's
interesting about this is that shape
displays really allow us to have a much
when we're coming from thinking about
graphical user interfaces they really
allow us to have a better way to map
these traditional interfaces into now 3d
interaction that can become physical and
material so for example the software
stack that we built is very similar to
how you would program a traditional
graphical user interface but we can also
do things like appropriate existing
objects as interface elements and use
the shape display to move them so for
example we can have a scroll bar where
or a play bar where the play bar is
actually moving the sphere and then you
can interact with it as well and so the
idea is not only to use the shape
display to display these dynamic
affordances directly but we can also use
appropriate passive objects as well and
so that means that we can do things like
move objects around the table so for
example if someone receives a phone call
but they're not looking at it then you
could actually sort of you know move
move the phone move the phone to them so
you know this is kind of like a little
fun example and so all of this is built
on this inform platform that Daniel
Lightning der and I built and so it's
kind of this brute force approach to how
you might build one of these systems so
it uses 900 linear actuators and then
these mechanical linkages to get a
higher or higher resolution in a smaller
footprint a larger footprint at the
bottom but you know this isn't how we
envision these being built in in the
long-term really we're interested in
using these two prototype new types of
interactions and applications so this is
sort of how we did it but but not
necessarily how one would do it if they
wanted to make a product or something
and so yeah as I mentioned there's 900
actuators and we ended up you
these Alps motorized slide
potentiometers for the actuators because
they're inexpensive but you can also
back drive them and they're very robust
the other thing that I think is one
interesting aspect of the in-form system
first prior shape displays is that it's
it's quite fast and I think that that
speed really allowed it to have this
interactive quality that we were going
for so that was something that I think a
lot of the other shape displays have
kind of slower types of actuation like
shape memory alloy or pneumatic systems
but here we really wanted to have
something that was fast and so we went
with these yeah in terms of the speed or
so I think definitely we wanted it to be
interactive but we've spent a lot of
time thinking about like why was this
why did this work so much better or was
more compelling than other shape
displays that for example lumen which is
Ivan popular Oh system I think is really
great and really exciting and it has
actually a very similar resolution it's
smaller it doesn't have as as many
pixels but it has about the same
resolution but it is much slower and so
I think that we did get a little lucky
that there was this nice sweet spot of
sort of speed cost and the number of
actuators that we used but I think it's
also interesting so previously Daniel
had built a lower resolution shape
display and that really didn't allow us
to display very many things and so this
kind of stepped to the next resolution
it wasn't an order of magnitude but
somewhere close to that I think really
got you a lot and so I think similarly
you'd find that if you jumped down
another step you you would probably find
even more interesting applications that
we can't really do with this just
because of the the scale of the pixels
so but yeah in terms of shape displays I
think there is this trade-off between
sort of the number of actuators that
you're using the cost and then the speed
or force and so it's kind of this
interesting space to work in so then we
develop these custom motor drivers and
it's all connected
this RS 45 bus and then we can update it
at 60 frames per second although you
know with the motor speed as I mentioned
before it kind of changes things and
then we have a depth sensing camera from
above to track input and then we can
also sense the position of the pins for
interaction so after building the system
one thing that we thought a really
interesting application for this was
collaborative design and collaboration
across distances and so one because when
we're interacting in person we use you
know physical objects we sketch on paper
and we aren't just looking at someone's
face so we're trying to think about how
we could have a richer sense of
collaboration at a distance and one of
the advantages of these shape displays
is that you can do something across a
distance like that so we work Daniel and
I work together on this notion of
physical telepresence so how could we
create this shape display system that
could both not only display content and
user interface but should also display a
remote person as well and so as I
mentioned you know when we're
collaborating in person especially
around design tasks we have physical
artifacts and space that we really use
as part of this process and I think that
you know there are you know in this
space you know people objects and tools
and then the environment as well and and
when we think about what we imagine you
know remote collaboration to be like you
know maybe we think more about this sort
of skype based windowing metaphor and
obviously there's been a lot of work in
telepresence and shared workspaces
obviously I see John Donne there who's
who's done some great pioneering work
there but we're still sort of limited to
this screen based interaction and so the
question is how can we use these shape
displays to now enable this type of rich
collaboration that we have in person but
at a distance and so we think that
there's sort of four aspects to this
approach that are really important so
one is physical embodiment so how can we
capture and remotely render a person's
body parts
and gesture is using this system so so
here you can see that we use the shape
display to represent a remote users
hands second is interaction with
synchronized remote objects so here if
you have two people that are
collaborating you can actually
manipulate the same linked object and
then that will you know get translated
across distances then thirdly we want to
talk about how we can go beyond this
one-to-one mapping of a representation
of a person to expand their capabilities
and so this notion of you know beyond
being there physically how can you
actually make the person who's remote
have more capabilities and be better
than if you were collaborating in person
so some of these things are around like
changing the scale or giving people
multiple arms and then finally how can
we manipulate shared content by
deforming it directly and so here you
can think about having two linked 3d
models and you can collaborate them as
well and so as I mentioned there's
there's been a lot of work in shared
workspaces and physical telepresence
that that have really inspired us so as
I as I mentioned you know video
whiteboard big inspiration also Hershey
issues work on clear board and many
other systems allow you to have this
richer sense of interaction but still
don't have the physical side of things
so then there's been a lot of other
systems that have looked at how you can
have you know embodied remote
collaboration through for example
robotic telepresence but then also some
work on tangible remote collaboration
but here you know really the physical
telepresence through teller robotics has
focused on you know mobility so how can
you have this physical embodiment that
can move around a space and the tangible
remote collaboration has sort of focused
on the shared workspace and so what we
wanted to do was sort of focus on this
shared workspace but have more of this
physical embodiment of a remote user and
so to do that we're we're using these
shape display systems that that I've
previously described
so in terms of physical telepresence we
can we can as I mentioned before you
know use this to represent content and
then we can spatially reference the
content we can actually manipulate
objects at a distance you know simple
objects then we can have linked objects
and then we can augment people's
capabilities trying to go beyond being
there and then also manipulate shared
content so first I'll talk about this
spatial referencing and annotation and
the idea is really to have this common
ground the people can together you know
reference and understand and think
through problems by having this physical
representation and being able to
manipulate that as well as being able to
see spatially where you're where you're
interacting so the way that we're able
to do that is that we capture a remote
participant using a depth sensing camera
and then we can represent them on the
shape display as well as content so here
you can see we can have this low
resolution model of a pan aircraft and
then I'm able to actually you know
spatially reference it in 3d and and so
that can really help people you know
collaborate and discuss around 3d
information but we can also provide that
remote user additional displays so that
they can sort of see what's going on so
here here we have a 2d display that's
showing a top-down view of the the
remote system but that allows you to
really have this you know spatial
referencing abilities but I think what's
really important about this system is
that you know now as opposed to you
could imagine doing something similar to
that if you had some type of 3d display
or augmented reality but really now with
the with the shape display we can
actually manipulate objects that might
not be virtual as well and so for
example you can reach out and lift up a
you know an object and manipulate it so
that allows you to spatially reference
and then also manipulate these objects
and so there's different ways you can
manipulate with them with the system and
then here's sort of what the remote side
sees
so a lot of the things we were doing
because we only had one shape display
with this one-way interaction and so you
can you know kind of have you know
improvise with different objects as well
and then you can start to manipulate you
know more complex objects a lot of the
limitations here in in the manipulation
have to do with the degrees of freedom
of our display so if you have you know
robotic system then you have you know
six degrees of freedom here we have 900
degrees of freedom but they're all in
the same direction so we have a little
bit of you know redundancy there but it
allows us to do things like for example
improvise with physical objects so for
example here you can take a bowl and
then use that to manipulate something
Edison so you don't have to just use
your hands I think that sort of starts
to speak towards what's what here is
interesting beyond you know metella
manipulation with a robotic system is
the flexibility of it to change the end
effectors or to change you know the
material that you're using with it that
it starts to become more like how we
interact in person and so you know we're
also interested in this bi-directional
interaction and display but as I
mentioned we kind of only had one shape
display so we split the display in half
and then you know but the the nice thing
is that you can you know take objects
and then they can appear on both sides
and you can you know go in and
manipulate them but we have sort of the
same limitations in terms of the input
side as well that we have you know 900
or 450 if you divide it half degrees of
freedom of input but it's all in in one
direction and so we thought about
different ways that we might be able to
manipulate objects at a distance so this
is a brush tool that then allows you to
push objects as opposed to just pressing
on them and so then it we tracked the
direction of the force and then there's
a switch on the brush that tells you if
you're pressing on the object as well
but then you know as I showed previously
we can think about linked objects as
well and manipulating those so here we
can have these synchronized tokens and
we can also rep
users physical presence as well or we
can you know just have the graphics but
then manipulate them and so you can kind
of have different ways of representing
things and you know really I think what
we want to do is not only make
collaboration you know as good as it is
in person I think we can really start to
think about how we can make a richer
type of collaboration and you know
there's just great paper beyond being
there and I think we didn't start to
think about that for this type of
physical telepresence as well and so we
were really inspired by you know things
like stell art with having you know a
third arm or this scene from ghost in a
shell where you have like a thousand
fingers or or things like more practical
things like the da vinci surgical robot
where it'll you know cancel out tremors
and allow you to remotely do surgery and
so we wanted to think about how we could
go beyond these bodily limits that we
have and so we can change the output
modality of of the person so we can you
know allow them to sort of move around
objects by becoming kind of ghost ghost
mode is what we like to call it but that
allows you to sort of not knock over
things but then that can also be useful
for like referencing on top of things
due to our limitations you can't
actually move above something but then
we can also have you know different
transformations as I showed previously
so you can scale or rotate a person's
hand which could be useful for our
mirror as well so this could be useful
for example if you have a larger object
then maybe you need larger hands to
manipulate it and so you can go in and
scale those hands up that allows you to
actually have more force than as well
and then on the on the remote side you
can actually you know you zoom in and
out of this scene and then you can see
the smaller version as well so these
mappings sort of work across these
things but you can also think about
replicating hands so here I can you know
if I'm helping someone with a soldering
task or something I can
lock a hand and freeze a hand there but
still have two hands to do something
else but then we can go further and sort
of replace people's hands with other
types of representations so kind of as I
mentioned as opposed to you know a
robotic telepresence system where you
might have one type of end effector here
we can have end effectors that we can
you know manipulate on demand so we can
replace a user's hand by tracking it
with you know these different types of
end effectors and obviously we're
limited by the resolution of our display
but I think it's interesting to think
about the flexibility that this has
versus some other types of systems and
finally you know we can also think about
how we can have you know shared content
that we're able to then manipulate as
well so if we had you know this these
are our two lower resolution shape
displays that we had and so the idea is
you know if you had to higher resolution
ones you could have a shared physical
model that you could then manipulate
across distances and I think that's
something that we're working on now at
our group at Stanford is thinking about
how do we build these higher resolution
shape displays that can allow for more
collaborative design at a distance and
so you know as I mentioned these are all
built on this informed platform but the
basic system diagram is that we capture
the person with the shapes and depth
sensing camera and then we have these
feedback screens for them in the
asymmetric tell operation set up and
then we send that data over the network
or on a computer to our shape display
and then we can project a content on
that there and then the bi-directional
system is you know very similar and for
that we used this transform system which
we built for this Milan so on it for the
Milan design fair which is basically a
lower resolution shape display but has
multiple segments so we use that for
that so we did some preliminary
evaluation to see you know how could
people actually manipulate objects at a
distance would that work because there's
a number of limitations with our system
you know some of which are fairly
obvious in that the pins can only move
up and down and normally when we push
things we have you know forces kind of
you know in contact with the object as
opposed to just sort of moving it
tilting it then also the refresh rate of
our display is somewhat limited and so
for the systems you you know you have
foretell operations you want to minimize
the latency we have a fairly high high
latency and so we wanted to see how
could people interact and then what are
the ways that they would use this system
to manipulate objects oh here's the sort
of test setup that we had where we had
on one side you know the asynchronous
control side where you have this view
and then on the other side you have the
shape display and then we wanted to see
if the lack of this haptic feedback you
know so you can't actually feel what
you're manipulating either and the
latency would present problems and to
see what types of interactions people
would use to manipulate objects so we
have three different conditions but I'm
the details are in our paper but
basically some of the interesting things
were you know the different ways that
people were interacting with these
things and so you you'd see these
different you know creating these
different shapes to enclose things or
using the back of your hand and what I
think this speaks to is sort of the
flexibility of the system because you
can have this freedom to manipulate
these things in different ways but
obviously you know I think there are a
number of limitations with this type of
approach versus something like a teller
robotic manipulation system and a lot of
those stem from you know the shape
display itself like the resolution of it
the limited degrees of freedom and that
you can't really grasp objects as well
and the cost of such a system because it
has so many actuators but I think it's
really you know points towards a new way
of thinking about this type of
telepresence and so you know in the
future we think we can have you know two
of these higher resolution ones as I
mentioned and also we can connect it
with you know augmented reality so you
can have richer 3d graphics on top and
so we had a chi paper it was about some
of that before and then
we also installed this set up at the
cooper-hewitt design museum and so we
recorded interactions with people
manipulating things and so we're looking
through there also to kind of understand
for a walk up scenario what are the
interesting things that people are doing
so so I think to me shape displays are
this kind of exciting area to that
allows you to do so many different
things with it to render 3d models but
also create these new types of
interfaces but they're all kind of have
the same you know form factor of you
know 2.5 d resolution with an array of
actuator so right now you know we've
been thinking about what are different
form factors that we could create to
create new types of shape changing
displays that that might be you know
allow for new types of interaction and
so I'm quickly going to talk about a
project that Ken knocked a jockey led
that i was at co advising with hiroshi
well i was doing a postdoc at the media
lab that he's going to be presenting a
twist this year and the idea is you know
as opposed to having a sheep display
where you have all these degrees of
freedom which are in this 2d array here
we have a 1d array of actuators that can
then create a curve that you can
manipulate and so that can look like
whoops deck plate twice so that can look
like this so here you can have the
system that you can manipulate but it
can also snap into different shapes and
at it can also do so you know not as you
know drastically so we can use that for
mobile interaction for kind of physical
feedback or other types of interfaces
and so you know we were really inspired
by you know snake robotics and and
looking at the kind of different types
of geometries that people have used in
continuum robotics and other types of
robotics and how do we then apply some
of those two interaction but you know
there's also been a lot of work in in
you know art that's used these really
beautiful kinetic installations of line
to convey information so not only to you
know in the stink robotic state robot
case to you know manipulate things
and also move across distances here we
can use lines to actually display
information and then obviously there's
been some work in HCI look thinking
about how might you interact with
deformable curves and then you know some
work also on how you might use a curve
to display information but there hasn't
been so much work on this as to date and
so we think there's really interesting
possibilities for this in terms of you
know display we can use a line to create
lots of different shapes both in 2d or
in 3d or to create solid volumes as well
and those can be used for things like
data visualization to represent iconic
forms or also to create you know
interface elements as well as creating
you know ergonomic forms or things that
provide aesthetic value as well and then
we can interact with these curve based
displays in a variety of ways and so we
can deform them we can touch them we can
pinch them and so there's a lot of
different interactions that are possible
when you're thinking about a curved
versus a solid versus you know only
touch on a surface then we can actually
use them to constrain our interaction as
well so here's some of the prototypes so
we have two different versions one is
this larger version which has two
degrees of freedom / joint and so that
can create these 3d shapes but then we
also have a smaller version which is
only 2d but then it's higher resolution
and so these are sort of the different
characteristics between the two and so
we don't have input sensing on the
smaller one but it gives you this much
higher resolution and and the way that
this works is that we have this array of
servo motors that are connected to each
other and then they talked to a computer
and so here's some of the applications
that we've explored with them so one is
using it as a mobile device so it can
actually you know be this wristband that
can give you notifications but then you
can sort of
unwrap it and then it can sort of change
into this touch sensitive input device
you know for kind of more touch base
interaction and then I could actually
change into the sort of the shape of a
phone and and so this is Ken who did
most of this work and so the second
direction that we've looked at is you
know how do we create shape changing
chords that might be able to both be
used as input and as output so here you
can have this adaptive toward where you
can have parts of it become the
interface itself or we can use these
same types of chord based interfaces to
display information so this is
connecting to a laptop so you can as you
drag a file it can give you feedback
there as well ah yeah so in terms of
human scale or ah yeah yeah so
definitely so there's a lot of work in
thinking about folding and thinking
about you know kind of using protein
folding not only to solve problems in
biology but also as a way of thinking
about new mechanisms for you know
designing you know human scale devices
and also things like that so I
definitely encourage you to look at the
Center for bits and atoms at MIT that's
been looking at a lot of things inspired
by these molecule and protein based
systems so they have this cool project
called the mill emo teens which are
these different reconfigurable chain
systems yeah and so then the video that
was shown here is thinking about how to
how you can use that for interactive
feedback and control but you can also
you know constrain interaction on you
know a 2d surface as well so here is
this kind of smart ruler so you can
create these lines of different sizes
and shapes and things like that but I
think it's interesting to think about
how we can also augment traditional
practices as well so because it's in the
physical world we have this flexibility
and then finally you know we can use
this type of thing for computer-aided
design as well so here you can have you
know as you're manipulating this curve
in the physical world that can be
transferred to the digital world and
then you can do things like you know
snap to grid physical snap to grid or
rendering hidden jizz or mirroring and
so all these things that you can do that
we've developed these wonderful
interaction techniques for in the
digital world we can now take those to
the physical world which is interesting
so finally I want to just really quickly
do run through some other work that
we've been doing kind of in the in the
mobile space and some of that's been
going on here at Stanford but i think
really you know as we've seen this trend
in computing moving from you know the
desktop to our mobile devices more and
more we interact on the go and i think
that still the the mobile device you
know an iphone there's over a million
apps in the App Store but it has the
same static physical interface how can
we adapt some of these techniques to
these different to the mobile
application yes swimming about those
stinking the mood of walking of
resolution in to expect for that I mean
you showed us a couple of examples where
they're like using for 3d modeling and
stuff off what kind of resolution
does it have yes certainly so I think
that again a lot of the work that we're
doing so far is really not thinking
about you know what are the techniques
or technologies for implementing it
today but rather what can we do with the
technology that we have today to explore
these new types of interactions and so
the current prototypes the shape display
as well as the line form are very low
resolution but i think you know along
the lines of what i was talking about in
terms of you know stuff that's going on
at the center for bits and atoms and
also in soft robotics and these types of
domains i think there is a lot of
exciting work going on in robotics in
thinking about different scales and we
can benefit from this as well but so to
answer your question of the exact
resolution of our current prototype I
think it's about two centimeters is
about the resolution of the small one
yeah
so as I said you know we want to have
this more rich mobile interaction and so
this was a project with linen yeah
that's called nuit which uses pneumatic
actuation kind of similar to the
application that was shown in the line
form where it can change shape between
you know this wristband to you know this
but here it uses less actuators but with
smarter materials that can give you this
richer shape change and then also you
know we can think about device and it's
devices where we can actually reform
them ourselves so as opposed to having a
system reform then we can use different
techniques to allow users to change the
shape so this is a project from wisc
paper from 2012 about jamming user
interfaces so we could detect this shape
that we're deforming something into and
then lock it into these shapes using
this jamming technique which changes the
stiffness of materials and then finally
we're working now at Stanford on
thinking about how we can take some of
the ideas from shape displays and use
them as tactile interfaces for mobile
devices so this is a project led by sun
joon jane and lawrence kim and kessler
tanner that allows you to have both in
pocket it tactile interaction as well as
in your hand so we can just the same
render these dynamic physical
affordances and you can interact with
them and you can create these buttons
that you can touch and interact with and
then inside we have you know all these
linear actuators give you this tactile
feedback and so finally I think you know
it's clear to to me at least that
computers are really everywhere and out
there on our desktop their inner pockets
but increasingly there you know in our
walls in pretty much every device we buy
and so I think it's interesting to think
about as opposed to just interacting
with computing how do we interact with
our environment and how do we have our
environment physically adapt to us at as
well and so Daniel Hiroshi and I built
this system called transform for the
Milan furniture fair and then lutra Fink
and Ken knockin gawky and virg con made
this interactive prototype to think
about you know how do we have furniture
scale interaction
we're where we have this type of
adaptive physical system whereas you
bring a device over to it it can adapt
to you and provide the physical
affordances that you need but you can
also use it to display information and
move objects around as well and so the
idea is to think less about you know
this notion of you know the future of
computing and instead think about the
the future of our environments and so
you know this is sort of a music
displaying application and I think the
next yeah the next one is my favorite so
ken can build this so it actually really
does work that it'll flip these cards
over which I thought was kind of amazing
but yeah so so I think you know this
sort of to me points to a new way of
interacting with our environment where
we're not only sensing people in space
but now we can actually physically
interact and physically out put things
in different spaces and to me where this
points to is this notion of maybe
thinking about how do we move from the
current age of ubiquitous computing to
thinking about ubiquitous robotics and
so just as computers don't really look
like this today robots probably won't
look like this in the future and so how
do we as designers and human-computer
interaction experts start to think about
you know this coming trend of increasing
amounts of robotic devices in our lives
and how do we think about those not just
being used for mobility but now for
interaction and really trying to enrich
our lives and so I think this you know
is across scales from thinking about you
know the interaction on your body
robotic interaction on devices all the
way up to environments and furniture and
so as I said it's sort of this space of
you know human centered design robotics
and sensing as well as interaction
techniques that's that I think points
this this way forward that could be very
exciting around this notion of
ubiquitous robotics so in conclusion I
believe that we really need computers
that can physically adapt to us
I for one am you know fed up with the
ways that we interact with computers and
i think that there's a lot of
possibilities to really learn from and
build on the cognitive science of how we
understand information and how we can
manipulate things in the physical world
and and i think that's a really exciting
direction for me so with that I'd like
to think by many many collaborators on
this and I'd be happy to take any
questions so in terms of deforming the
importance of lay right and you can like
push down on pixels and I seems the
opposite direction would be like to try
to pull off on cam you're pulling has of
course a lot of limitations for Jim you
seem really pull one thing that I'm in
it needs to be like in a place where ya
dilate have you considered like the
dressing belly yes yes so I think that
is a big limitation in the way that you
interact with these systems so we have
actually thought a lot about that and so
daniel has a paper from with 2011 that's
called i forget the exact name of it but
if you look up light finger 2011 that
talks about different ways that you can
manipulate the shape displays based on
this problem that you know if you have
concavities that are too you know too
small or you know you can't pull up the
pins so some of the things that we've
looked at are you know doing things with
gesture so you can use gesture to
interact but then also you can do things
to you no sense where the user is and
then you know provide these dynamic
affordances that allow you to manipulate
things as well so i think that that's a
good point and i think that it really
does speak to that's only one of the
limitations of how you would interact
with it you also can't you know apply
force laterally or or other things so i
think that there are still you know a
lot of limitations with these shape
displays and just now we're starting to
think about how we might build
interaction techniques to support more
interaction and some of those I think
are you know trying to solve the
limitations of specific systems I think
some of those are sort of key to this
class of interfaces as well so
this is all really cool and Leonard when
it gets to consumer products based on us
what are your concerns and willing to be
doing for safety purposes you need all
these objects on this desk and like this
seems like a great way to send this cell
phone flying yeah like so yeah I want
that so so I think that is a really
interesting point and I think beyond
just the actual safety so you could make
this system safe and you could make it
you know and I think also you know in
robotics there's a lot of talk about the
shift towards soft compliant robots that
are much safer than you know other
things so so I think there's a
technological solution but then there's
also this I think what you identified
correctly is this psychological one as
well that you know normally other than
other animals or you know people things
don't really move or change shape very
quickly in the real world and so we've
been doing a lot and running some
studies to better understand you know
how do people perceive this shape change
and how can we sort of build in either
feed forward into the system so we can
clue the users into how things might be
changing too or how things might be
moving as well as you know what are the
right speeds at which to move things so
I think there is a lot of interesting
things to think about around that and
definitely an intersection with a lot of
the stuff going on in terms of human
robot interaction in terms of thinking
about the safety and how the perceived
safety of these systems and so a lot of
the work there is thinking about if you
have if you're collaborating with this
you know robotic system which has you
know arms or something how do you you
know when when we r you know talking to
someone else or interacting with the
person we actually you know there's a
lot of lead in and gesturing and social
cues that we pick up on that you know
are how we don't surprise each other all
the time and so we have to think about
how we can build that into our systems
as well so i think the social and
psychological aspect i think is really
exciting or interesting for us as a
research community to think about so
the testicle be the tactic feedback on
everything that you could you develop
like why and how day like there's a lot
of touchscreens the everyone's using but
like there's a reason people are still
using your physical keyboards they know
where their fingers are entertaining so
I see that is like something that could
be really really successful like having
a touchscreen actually more sweater so
like I've just like if you could talk a
little more about it like timeline maybe
it like something like that sure so well
in terms of the keyboard that can
physically adapt there's a startup
company or I don't know if there's
startup or if they're just a company but
called tactus which is working on
creating yeah basically a display and it
has basically these microfluidic
chambers that inflate and the index of
refraction of the fluid is the same as
like this glass i guess and so basically
it can inflate these little bubbles over
keys and stuff so so i think that's like
a near term solution and they I think
you know they have I don't know if it's
actually in any you know consumer device
now but they've been around for a long
time and trying to get people to put
this in but then I think you know I it's
possible with the shape displays that
they could take a similar trajectory to
something like 3d printing or computing
in general in that you know maybe
there's these applications where they
make sense for you know design or for
you know geospatial information or
something like that where you have them
you know in a workplace in it's a shared
type of thing but over time you know
more and more people the cost goes down
and more people can have them so that's
that's one possibility but i think that
yeah i think there's different ways to
approach the commercialization problem
but i think it is a big big challenges a
lot of this you know basically a display
engineering has gotten so good the
displays are so cheap right and right
now motors aren't that cheap and so the
question is you know is there you know
this physical limitation to the price or
is it just that we haven't spent as much
time engineering clever systems and also
reducing the cost of these things so
what out what a web to you as being the
killer apps and you can start with the
sheet system and some of the other cool
and it's as if you showed and and what
kind of improvements to hardware and
cost economics would you like to see to
enable those sure there's the
low-hanging fruit yeah yeah so I need to
me really the low-hanging fruit or the
applications where it makes the most
sense is sort of 3d spatial information
so things like you know computer-aided
design things like geospatial
information things like command and
control where you you have a lot of data
that is 3d that you want to collaborate
on that you want to manipulate and I
think that you know computed design
tools have reached in some way cases
this sort of plateau where they haven't
really become that much easier to use in
a long time and so I think this could
really play a big role there but then
you know how do we get it there even to
that so I think really you're going to
need more resolution and so I think one
way to think about that is to move
beyond sort of having M times n type of
thing where you need so many actuators
to trying to find a way to have
something like an M plus n type of
system so if you have you know valves or
something like that so there's some work
out of Georgia Tech on doing this type
of approach where you have you can kind
of you know go through the the display
serially to control it so that's that's
one thing is just trying to find other
ways to reduce the number of actuators
and so I briefly showed this newly paper
which was about using pneumatic
composites and there's a lot of work in
soft robotics also that are looking at
how you can use fewer number of
actuators with mechanical constraints to
give you you know much richer types of
motion and so I think that's another
possibility as well as thinking about
smarter ways as opposed to this brute
force approach of having all these
pixels which I think from a computer
science and graphics perspective we like
pixels we
know how to interact with them but there
might be you know that's not really how
nature works right there aren't you know
these grid based systems that you find
in nature very often so John we use that
line robot to give sort of feedback um
wrapped around an arm I wanted about
combining that with like augmented
reality or kind of a visual picture of
something with that feedback yeah yeah
so I think that's really interesting
direction we haven't tried it out yet as
well i think you know there are some you
know and in some cases you know you
could just think about it like an
exoskeleton and robotic exoskeleton so I
don't think like in terms of like the
research in terms of how you would do
something like that I don't think
there's that much novelty there but
rather you know what I think is
interesting about this is sort of the
flexibility that you could you know use
it for different things like if you have
a robotic exoskeleton it's just a
robotic exoskeleton versus this to be
used for you no interaction with curves
or other types of things but but I do
think you know virtual reality is
obviously really a big deal in Silicon
Valley right now and I think you know
maybe this is the time that it takes off
we'll see but but I think a big part of
that is once people are gonna you know
once people are seeing things in 3d
they're going to want to touch them they
want to feel them and so I think that's
definitely a direction that we're
thinking about as well as how do you
build cheaper types of haptic feedback
for virtual reality Florida fairs Lewis
oh d back yeah yeah so we haven't
personally go to that you much but there
are some other groups that have for
tactile feedback so there's a belief
yawn Borchers group had a project called
mud pad which trying to remember the
name of the grad student but but anyway
so yeon borders and mud pad used mr
fluid inside of a sealed flexible
membrane and then they had a number of
magnetic basically electromagnets an
array of electromagnets that you could
then feel stiffness different
isn't stiffness so I think that's an
interesting approach I think you know
and you see these sculptures I forget
the name of the artists who do these
wonderful things where you have like
these really strong electromagnets and
then they create these really amazing
patterns around it the kind of thing is
that the ferrofluid is actually kind of
toxic so you can't directly touch it so
you need to somehow wrap it in something
but I think I mean that's very
interesting and so I think you know I
showed just you know a subset of the
ways that you can potentially think
about the shape-changing interfaces but
there's you know so many different types
of actuation technologies the people and
robotics are exploring and other domains
such as art and so I think it's really a
exciting place to be thinking about
Michael coincidence I oh and changing
this place so like you think about these
these patterns with bendable displays
are very very small displays like
imagine pixels are actually on the units
is that far off near that's going to
change or is it gonna be similarly so I
don't think it will change too much the
so we're using projection mapping and so
I think you know we're using a single
projector you could use multiple
projectors such that you could probably
solve a lot of the occlusion problems so
i think that there's a lot of cost and
adding physical displays to this right
now and and at the resolution so where I
think this sort of connects is you know
if you have something at the scale of
inform it doesn't make sense to really
add a single pixel / / pin because it's
so low resolution so you'd want to add
something like a screen and there have
been some papers like Jason Alexander
had this tilt display paper from mobile
HD I that was basically doing something
like that where you have like small LCD
screens and then you move them but i
think really you want to have not only
on the top you want at all on the side
and so I think that yeah we're a little
far away from having that kind of
flexible display where it could be you
know very cheap but i think you know
combining flexible displays with
pneumatic actuation or with other type
evacuation is really exciting
unfortunately the flexible displays are
not really there yet in terms of their
flexible in that you sort of at least
the ones from like Samson or that are
commercially available are like you can
flex them like once and then they glue
it in place and that's what they mean by
flexible so I think there are you know I
think there are a lot of exciting things
at this intersection but right now the
display technology is not quite there I
think five years from now it'll be
different story so close it takes a lot
of mechanical engineering another
building effort to get these displays
working i'm curious your own design
process like how did you prototype early
on yeah a display did you ever play with
one of those braille displays incision e
doing the interest first so the way that
we approach the protagonist do we built
a stop motion prototype before we even
began building it so basically i think
like the first month that i arrived at
MIT I was like oh I saw Daniels lower
resolution shave display and I was like
oh so be awesome if we could use this
for cad if it was higher resolution and
so Daniel and I built laser-cut like
basically made a giant pin screen toy
and then made a stop motion animation of
what could be the interactions for for
this type of thing and then we had this
video and we were like oh this is
actually pretty compelling and so then
we also had this physical prototype that
we could use for interacting with other
things so we when we were doing the
dynamic affordances we would also like
put stuff underneath and and for
creating constraints that you would move
things in so we did a lot of things with
having this passive prototype before we
actually build the thing and then you
know we did a lot of prototyping around
different resolutions as well so we
would 3d print things at different
resolutions so so more that was on the
kind of physical prototyping and then
for a later project for the Milan
furniture fair Phillip schuessler who
was working on it with us built
basically a version of that system
before we built it physically in I think
it would
trying to remember I think 3d studio Max
and so then he built a plug-in that
would allow you to you know animate
things on 3d studio max and it would get
rendered on the shape display and so you
could prototype that before we even had
the actual thing that we were building
so I think there's sort of two
approaches one is you know how can you
do this in software and then how can you
do you know understand the physical
thing but yeah we we had played with
some Braille displays and we also had
you know Daniel had built this lower
resolution one first so i can't speak to
what he did before that to better
understand that but we had that as well
so John her alone oh yeah the living
more yeah I'm picturing a cute does it
display on every face so you can solve
it just by pushing a button and I'm
going to be the same color on your face
but then you wouldn't have to mess it up
it would mess itself up then you'd have
to solve the problem yeah a simple
display one color on each face they can
also be instrumented you could sense
what you're very satisfying yeah I love
the feeling everything about the Rubik's
using so many in one yeah I can't do it
with ring cubes struggling yeah exactly
but i think you know really the nice
thing about the rubik's cube is you have
this there's this friction and I think
maybe also details I don't remember
right yeah yeah so I think that would be
really a fun type of interface and yeah
Olivier bow who was working with Ivan
puppy Rev for a while he created this I
think they call it a d20 but it was
basically like a giant die you know I
think it's a deep I don't play enough
role-playing game so I don't know what
they have a lineage the different types
of things but basically it was like
trying to have input around this
multifaceted object and then Paul Paul
plah who is a penny mazes student was
working on these display blocks where
they had yeah displays on every side of
the service but i don't think i think
this combination of display and then
manipulation is really nice
yeah thanks thanks Bill alright thanks
Simon what's that
you